vous l'avez reconnu joueur de tennis
canadien Félix Eugène gassim ainsi que
plusieurs autres étoiles de ce sport les
documentaires sportifs sont de plus en
plus populaires sur les plateformes de
visionnement en continu en plus de
balles de Brie l'envers du décor il y a
drive de survive également sur Netflix
alors qu'est-ce qui explique l'intérêt
soudain des plateformes pour le contenu
sportif alternatif on en parle avec lui
la Londe expert en affaires du marketing
sportif merci beaucoup d'être là donc
qu'est-ce qu'on nous propose dans le cas
de balles de Brie breakpoint en
particulier et dans ces autres séries
qui se multiplient en ce moment c'est
une introduction dans l'intimité des
athlètes et des équipes aussi on prend
plusieurs angles puis on rentre dans
l'inconnu les consommateurs de sport qui
aiment le sport sont toujours curieux
intéressés d'aller plus loin pour en
savoir un peu plus si je l'ai mentionné
c'est un peu une forme de téléréalité ou
on voit des choses plus intimes dans
leur chambre d'hôtel dans les autobus
dans les voitures dans les restos en
famille on voit comment ils composent
avec le stress puis la pression puis
l'intensité devant un match après un
match ainsi de suite c'est bon pour
augmenter le rayonnement si on veut puis
si on veut dans le paysage du sport ils
cherchent toutes les marques toutes les
équipes en prendre plus de place dans le
marché des gens alors l'appétit et la
raison pour laquelle on a multiplication
est-ce que c'est parce que justement les
équipes les joueurs veulent se faire
voir davantage ou l'appétit vient-il du
téléspectateur ou de la plateforme
elle-même pourquoi on a notre plus en
plus je pense que l'appétit ça commence
avec le fait que les ligues les
organisations par exemple 15 février
c'est le début de fausses Swing qui est
la série sur le golf
produite par Netflix les mêmes
dirigeants qui ont
créé le Drive pour l'iPhone alors la F1
on avait besoin pour cette pénétration
dans le marché américain c'était le seul
marché du monde qui était pas conquis
par la Formule 1 alors Netflix
entreprise américaine Liberty médias qui
détient l'iPhone entreprise américaine
se sont joints qui sont mis ensemble
pour dire on pourrait créer du contenu
pour essayer d'éduquer d'informer les
gens parce que le tennis est un sport
qui est plus connu ça a pas besoin de
plus de popularité mais c'est une chance
de présenter des nouveaux visages les
nouvelles stars hommes et femmes qui
prennent la relève de Nadal Djokovic et
Federer ou Serena Williams par exemple
alors c'est une façon de continuer à ce
moderniser puis rester jeune et pour les
plateformes c'est du contenu frais
nouveau et c'est de l'argent et on a
augmenté alors c'est une façon de
séduire parce que là vous parlez de
balles de prix breakpoint par exemple on
présente des joueurs qui viennent de
toutes les régions du monde est-ce que
c'est une façon là d'aller séduire des
auditoires particuliers en faisant le
tour de la planète parce que ça fait
partie de la stratégie parce que je
pense que même un gars comme Félix qui
est évidemment immense populaire au
Canada bah il est une star mondiale du
tennis un jeune en devenir il est
populaire partout le tennis a un
avantage comme l'iPhone contrairement au
hockey par exemple c'est que c'est un
sport qui se mobilise dans tous les pays
du monde le circuit homme et femme fait
le tour du monde on va pas savoir ok on
va passer dans la NFL c'est très
nord-américain mais la F1 le fait le
tennis surtout et un peu de golf donc
ils ont l'avantage de pouvoir
exploiter les personnalités des athlètes
puis les emmener partout sur la planète
puis il y a des fans de Félix qui
habitent en Chine comme il y en a qui
habitent en Australie comme il y en a au
Canada parce que ces athlètes là
mais c'est pas là que eux ils voient le
bénéfice dans le rayonnement le fait
Félix soit sélectionné pour une émission
un épisode quasi complet
en vue de son match on affrontement
contre Nadal l'an dernier mais c'est
immensément important pour lui avec ses
nouveaux commentaires puis il continue
de rayonner puis la commercialisation
d'un gars comme Félix Félix hink si on
l'appelle mais ça prend un peu de plus
de poids lorsqu'il faut pousser comme ça
sur Netflix pour les plateformes sur la
langue est-ce que c'est
une famille les droits qui sont liés à
la diffusion des matchs en direct par
exemple est-ce que ça coûte extrêmement
cher ça coûte cher ça coûte cher de
produire des émissions comme celle-là
aussi mais le défi pour les plateformes
Andréane c'est toujours est-ce qu'on y
va dans la diffusion du sport en direct
est-ce qu'on touche pour mesurer un peu
la température de l'eau avant de se
décider pendant ce temps-là les
diffuseurs traditionnels linéaires ne
vivent que pour le sport en direct c'est
une des dernières choses qui gardent les
gens accrochés à la télé mais c'est pour
ça que les droits sont si chers
exactement et c'est pour ça que eux vont
payer coûte que coûte ce que ça va
prendre pour obtenir les droits
exclusifs mais en contrepartie les
League savent que la télé telle qu'elle
on la connaît dans 10 ans ça sera plus
comme ça alors ils ont besoin eux aussi
de se convertir vers du modèle vers de
la technologie puis d'exploiter les deux
si possible c'est pour ça que Apple TV
est avec MLS et le baseball majeur
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a un tableau
qui nous montre l'importance des
investissements de la valeur des
ententes dans ces cas-là MLS et Apple TV
plus 2 milliards et demi dollars sur 5
ans et vous alliez me parler de la LNH
bon la LNH est avec ISBN et Turner aux
États-Unis c'est pas linéaire c'est
câbler sa satellite mais leur prochain
entente expire dans quelques années au
Canada ils vont vouloir insérer une
portion c'est à dire couper un morceau
du gâteau puis le donner à une
plateforme numérique parce que ça donne
plus d'accès à de nouveaux partisans
éventuels plus de consommateurs égales
plus de vent plus d'acheteurs de billets
plus de produits dérivés faculté ils
peuvent pas s'éloigner de la technologie
et puis la modernisation ils doivent
rester très près de ça est-ce que c'est
une formule gagnante pour tout le monde
dans le fond pour les plateformes pour
les diffuseurs traditionnels pour le
sport pour les athlètes on y gagne pas
tous la même manière mais est-ce que
tout le monde y gagne
c'est plus payant pour les ligues pour
les ligues pour les équipes les athlètes
donc reçoivent une portion égale de ça
c'est payant pour les diffuseurs actuels
qui obtiennent du contenu qui est
vraiment recherchée
les gens veulent c'est pas quelque chose
de sport en direct qu'on attend au
lendemain une fois que le lendemain on
connaît le résultat on veut plus voir le
match on veut passer au suivant donc le
sport en direct à une énorme valeur mais
ces éléments-là de production là nous
amène à mieux comprendre puis
éventuellement on va consommer le sport
en direct tout le monde gagne bon alors
les plateformes entre autres et ça on le
présume merci beaucoup monsieur Lalande
d'avoir été là très bon tour d'horizon
et ça donne des idées pour la fin de
semaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI